du kannst immer höchst rips mir ja ganz
gut ich hallo leute ich sie doch mal
waren und heute ist der dritte tag der
geburtstagswoche aus marl war diese
folge wird ihnen präsentiert von apple
denn ich habe kein sticker der das logo
verdecken kann und ich könnte glaubt
apple a day keeps the doctor away ja das
mittlerweile schon wird bekommt diese
woche lade ich jeden tag ein video hoch
denn ich aber 99 also am samstag
geburtstag und das möchte ich mit euch
feiern und da jedes video zum
geburtstags thema passt schaut heute
nach ob die sternzeichen von youtube
auch zu ihnen passen also nach der
beschreibung verstehen sie okay mit
welchen youtuber fangen wir an wir
fangen einfach mal mit der queen auf
youtube an julien börse ging auf youtube
julien benneteau schon 28 jahre alt war
das macht mich gerade ein bisschen
pferde ist okay dreiundzwanzigster
elfter welches sternzeichen bis do
julien web ist schüssel der schütze
gehört genau wie auch der löwe und der
wieder zu den feuerzeichen er ist
freiheitsliebend weltoffen und liebt das
abenteuer also das passt schon mal
richtig guter ist fröhlich charmant und
geistreich fröhlich charmant auf jeden
fall und geistreich passt er möchte
verliebt sein
juliane ruf mich an hütet sich aber vor
einer bindung ist turin beim opfer geben
wahrscheinlich nicht menschen die im
sternzeichen schütze geboren wurden sind
mitreißender redner und laufen zur
höchstform auf wenn sie im mittelpunkt
des interesses steht das passt
unglaublich gut deck waren die videos
von the head am ende immer eine rede und
machtvoll die tiefsinnigen sachen
wundern sie sich also nicht wenn sie
ihnen als hochschulleiter richter oder
sein semantik du also falls es mit
youtube irgendwann nicht mehr klappt
warum auch immer du kannst
hochschullehrer richter oder reiseleiter
wäre reiseleiter leute einsatz wie das
kann ich nicht würde niemals von einem
schützen kommen ja das passt perfekt ich
muss ehrlich sagen ich halte nicht viel
von horoskopen also dass ich jemand
sagen kann deine woche mit gut oder
schlecht aber ich glaube schon an
sternzeichen dass die irgendwie zu uns
passen sieht man ja nix abkommt leute 1
nächstes schauen wir mal auf babys
sternzeichen zu ihr passt geboren
exter februar 1993 ist eine 93 sowie ich
baby ist ein wassermann was sie haben
besonders besonderer wassermann wie kein
anderes sternzeichen umgibt die
wassermann frau eine aura der
andersartigkeit gemixt mit einem kleinen
schuss exzentrik ist auf jeden fall
anders wie es baby ist eine sehr
besondere frau spontane ideen geistige
schnelligkeit und ein sensationelles
improvisationstalent machen dieses luft
zeichen zu einem der intellektuellen
überflieger baby als intellektuell zu
bezeichnen ist sehr mutig muss ich sagen
oh mein gott oder das zeigt jetzt dass
sie eigentlich so intelligent dass sie
diesen dummen content und diese dumme
art nur macht um erfolg auf youtube zu
haben was ihr auch ganz schön habt baby
ist eigentlich ein genie und das ist
alles nur eine masche
und weil wassermänner echte menschen
freunde sind möchte sind man sie am
liebsten die ganze welt mit innovation
reformen erfindung beschenken gemeinde
zugute kommt ja baby beschenkt uns
wirklich mit ganz vielen den muss man
echt sagen
kaum ein stern sehen hat eine so
humanistische und idealistische
einstellung wieder wassermann da kann
eigentlich nur noch der optimistische
schütze mithalten doch während schütze
geborene vor allem nach der persönlichen
freiheit streben hat das luft zeichen
wassermann gleich die freiheit aller
menschen im fokus nicht wie die
freiheitskämpferin gleich nach che
guevara und martin luther king und wie
sie alle heißen gandhi wie es auf einer
stufe mit dem wir wissen jetzt auf jeden
fall das baby eines genies und uns etwas
vorspielt well done the world
das macht voll spaß mit den nächsten
termin nehmen wir jetzt jemanden den ich
überhaupt nicht mal sam mendes julia
berger selter erzeugung des us- bin
irgendwie sei man deshalb wurde am 20
august 1991 geboren ist ein löwe der
löwe man kann großes leisten und es
ausgesprochen extrovertiert das stimmt
großes leisten er leistet sich viele
dinge aber ich kann muss der löwe mann
und die karriere autosuggestion ist eine
wunderbare sache wenn sie fest davon
überzeugt sind dass sie der beste sind
und ihn alles gelingt was soll da noch
schiefgehen
hinzu kommt dass der löwe man mit
minimalem aufwand maximalen erfolg
erzielt und exzellente
führungsqualitäten mit minimalem aufwand
maximalen erfolg es ist einfach der satz
der zu ihm am besten passt sein kannst
du das bitte in den kanal banner so
reinschreiben minimaler aufwand
maximaler erfolgten besonders gut liegen
ihnen auch berufe bei denen sie ihre
kreativität zum ausdruck bringen ich
habe noch nie etwas so kreatives gesehen
wie im schlamm zu baden alle leute die
an sternzeichen zweifel werden
spätestens jetzt mit auf meine seite
kommen ok wenn habe ich dann abonniere
ich will man jemanden nicht so großes
michael buchinger ich möchte wissen was
wir stellen seit michael buchinger ist
der ist für mich so eine interessante
person 21
oktober 1902
falls sie mich ja noch nicht kennt geht
auf jeden fall auf seinem kanal größten
von mir erst ein ganz ganz toller mensch
ein login
wer immer schwieriger entscheidungen
liegen den harmoniebedürftigen wagemann
nicht harmonie bedürfte hat ihn hass
liste ich glaubte es sich so wie
betrifft ist wichtigste eigenschaften
das vage man sie erkennen ihn an seinem
gepflegten äußeren check in einer
galerie fühlt er sich deutlich wohler
als auf dem sportplatz check und es gibt
wenig dass er für ein kultiviertes
gespräch auf augenhöhe eintauschen würde
jack waage männern glänzen als verkäufer
in der schönheitsbranche und als
therapeutin ich finde schon michael
brühn das videos haben eine
therapeutische wirkung auf mich
typische berufe für den wagemann
friseurs choreographie blume hat die
seiner tätigkeit in der werbebranche und
im journalismus ja immer leute was ist
michael grüner journalist als er
schreibt und ist somit ein journalisten
wer ist unser nächstes opfer unserer
letzten sternzeichen opfer ist aber
wendete wieder wenn weder perfekt gebaut
geburtstag dann rufe ich sie halt an
hallo emma kann ich dem internet
verraten welches sternzeichen du willst
ein separates geburtstag
ich verrate super danke dann mache ich
mal weiter ich weiß jetzt dass
geburtstag jetzt muss ich noch
herausfinden welches sternzeichen das
ist jeder ist fisch verträumt und
sanftmütig blickt die fische frau in die
welt verträumt und sanftmütig verträumt
und sahen verträumt und sanft verträumt
und sanftmütig und stellt früher oder
später zu seinem leidensweg sie fest
dass der blaue planet erde nicht nur mit
jeder menge schönheit aufwartet sondern
auch einiges an schrecken leid und
kummer bereiten viele fisch geborene
ertrag dieser erkenntnis nur bedingt sie
ziehen sich dann immer wieder einmal in
ihrer traumlandschaft zurück um dem
ganzen mehr voller fantasie und gefühl
zu verschwinden
die bestimmt der planet neptun ja
vielleicht machst du auch neptun bei
seiner monat gibt also er hat auf jeden
fall das tiefste nächste sternzeichen
von allen dabei wird sie immer so hart
jeder spielt uns etwas voreilig jetzt
rausgefunden bis endlich ein ganz zartes
blümchen was auf der wiese sitzen möchte
in den himmel schauen will und über das
universum nachdenken möchte also kannst
deine maske herunter die last but not
least lasst uns herausfinden ob mein
sternzeichen zu mir passt denn ich habe
ja diese woche geburtstag die jungfrau
bin ich ein scharfer intellekt gepaart
mit einer rasanten auffassungsgabe ich
bin für jungfrau geborene sind realisten
im tierkreis und sie nehmen die dinge
des lebens nicht nur über emotionen war
sondern so gut wie immer über ihr den
verstand dieser hypo realistischen blick
auf die welt kann dazu führen dass das
sternzeichen jungfrau manchmal vieles zu
schwarzen lernaufgabe besteht dann darin
offener für die schönen dinge des lebens
zu werden was habe ich gestern in meinem
video noch gesagt dass ich mir über
alles immer viel zu viele gedanken
machen
das liegt an meinem sternzeichen ein
bestimmter planet merkur element erde
spielt erde luft feuer wasser scheinbar
bis braun wenn der aufbau ist braun in
wissenschaft forschung oder
betriebswirtschaft werde ich richtig gut
ich mache den falschen beruf leute aber
beim jungfrau zuverlässig treue und
hilfsbereit ist wünscht sie sich genau
das auch von ihrem partner auch in
liebesdingen kann sie ihren verstanden
schwer abschalten findet sie aber einen
einfühlsamen partner der sie im wahren
sinne des wortes von ihrer
kopflastigkeit erlöst kann sie auch in
der liebe eine ungewohnte leidenschaft
an den tag legen die man hinter ihrer
beherrschten emotionalen fassade niemals
vermutet hätte wenn man mich nur
ordentlich genug geredet
ich finde es wirklich krass was
sternzeichen so über einen sagen können
was man selber nicht so richtig
wahrgenommen hat aber dann am ende doch
stimmt und ich weiß viele dann
hokuspokus und ja und der mann setzte
nimmt dann kann man sie immer irgendwie
auf jemanden zurechtrücken und immer
passt das dann irgendwie
aber es ist schon richtig dass ein teil
des ju ein löwe irgendwie ist und und so
aus sich raus kommt ein michael bringer
an der waage ist und irgendwie das mit
journalismus und so passt und und dieses
vielleicht auch tiefsinnige malta
da muss ich auch sagen wer kenn ich da
noch nicht gut genug wäre ob sie die ist
beschnitten
eine maske auf aber auch turnier werben
so und bei mir ich muss es sagen es
passt ich hasse es nämlich dass ich
immer so verkopft bin ich denke über
alles immer 100 mal nach ich bin jemand
der menschen sofort verurteilt oder
beurteilt aber auch sich natürlich
irgendwie lassen sich aber auch gerne
vom gegenteil überzeugen wenn ich ein
bild von jemandem hat aber trotzdem ist
das schon passend habt ihr schon mal
geschaut aber eher sternzeichen zu euch
passt wenn nicht dann macht das auf
jeden fall mal es ist ganz interessant
muss ich sagen und dann sehen wir uns
auch schon morgen wieder bei den
nächsten video hier findet ihr ein video
dorf findet ihr ein video hier unten
könnt ihr mich abonnieren wie immer
präsente bubis denn jugel member of our
family ich sollte definitiv
englischlehrer jetzt ja bis touches ich
bin intellektuell
[Gelächter]